[Music]
hi i'm ellie kemper are you
okay great
so uh let's
get to know each other
[Music]
oh i'm an actress oh yeah
um probably the thing that you're most
likely to have seen would be the office
which was a sitcom on nbc
i could watch any episode of the larry
sanders show i love that show also the
comeback those are shows i go to when i
need just a little pick-me-up but also
some comfort
it does feel like home i really like new
york um i've lived here now for
oh my gosh off and on for 20 years and i
i love it here i love the diversity and
the
range of stuff to do and the busyness
and it feels very vibrant
you know a quintessential new york
moment is probably what happens
pretty much
every day which is that new yorkers go
about their own business and once we
were filming a scene from unbreakable
kimmy schmidt which is another sitcom i
was in and we were in the heart of times
square and we were you know singing and
dancing and we were getting in
everyone's way and the only thing that
happened is people were annoyed that we
were interrupting them on their way to
work nobody stopped and stared i was
just like get out of my way i'm trying
to get to my real job that's all that it
is and then they're like can you please
not walk and you're like because you
decided to film here i have to stop no
i have been having the weirdest dreams
lately but they won't make any sense and
they're usually so obvious it's just
from something that happened that day
like there was this really aggressive
squirrel in the park when we were eating
lunch the other day and that night i had
a dream about like a monster squirrel
i'm so simple it's so dumb but it's true
oh i you know 15 year old me might think
that i was uh cool is the wrong word i
think 15 year old me would be like wow
you made it to 41.
keep going
i would rate this date as a nine mostly
because i've been doing most of the
talking and i love to hear myself talk
well listen this has been really fun but
i actually have to get going
wait a minute also i just remembered i'm
married
[Music]
you